I sold my motor I sold one of my ninja
600 still a guy
he showed when I was like 25 he showed
up with his girlfriend because his
girlfriend like drop them off and you
know and it's like paid me the cash I
was like 1,200 bucks or something he got
on the knees
he took off down the street it's
actually the street where this picture
is like he took off down the street
I was like waving goodbye to him he goes
in and dumps it
he totally crashes it on the first turn
he's ever taken on a motorcycle and he
comes back he's got road rash all over
him he's shakin like a leaf because when
you crash a motorcycle yeah totally free
job died I'm still standing on my lawn
with this 1,300 bucks in my gym pants
you know and he goes IIIi don't want the
bike I don't want the bike anyway I
don't want the bike anymore I want my
money back and I was like well you have
to sell your motorcycle let's sell more
you're you you can sell it I'm not
buying it you can sell it he goes I did
I just want the money back and it's like
normally you can [ __ ] people but I'm
holding the money and standing on my
lawn like he knows I have his cash right
it wasn't a check or anything so he goes
I just want my money back and I'm like
well I don't know what kind of damage
you did to the bike or whatever and so
he goes I don't want anything to do with
it and I'm like okay well good by the
way because you would have killed your
I'm sure so I go all right let me see if
I can figure this out
I rode the motorcycle to a like an
independent motorcycle repair shop
the gear shift the peg was busted off
the right side
yeah I'm trying to think Oh brakes on
the right yeah I think the UH no brakes
on the left gear shifts on the right you
got to check me out that one ever ridden
one well but he another brakes on the
right in the gear so anyway he broke the
peg off on the gearshift side yeah
that's the brake on the right so the
gear shifts on the left he broke the peg
off so I had to ride this motorcycle too
a motorcycle repair place with no peg
like if you can't put your heel on
something and shift up and down and to
squirt foot like floating in the air
like trying to kick nice kick it down
I wrote it into this place they repaired
the bike it cost a hundred bucks
I wrote it home like two two days later
I get a call because this is back when
it was in the recycler newspaper like no
internet anything it's like some guy
calls me he's like you still got that
bike for sale like kind of and and it's
like he's like I'll take it and I sold
it to another guy the guy who was
freaked out I just took the hundred
bucks at back the hundred bucks out that
it cost to fix the bike and just sent
him send him the new check so yeah I'm
sure the guy bought it guys Murray man
you remember a lot of details it's a
weird story that I'll never forget right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]